[Música]
mariano lópez es responsable de acción
social en el velero escuela eco maris
bienvenido a radio canadá internacional
gracias a luego de días buenos dias un
gusto tenerte con nosotros maria no
hacía rato que no habíamos conversado
si de verdad los años pasa les pasa y no
pasan en vano bueno el mariano tú forma
parte de la tripulación del velero
escuela eco maris para beneficio de
todos explícanos por favor cuál es la
labor del eco maris que sí que hace eco
maris bueno
yo soy parte del equipo de comer y que
es un velero de que tiene como que se es
un velero donde se aprende a navegar
dentro de esa de las acciones que tiene
ese velero ese barco es tener una acción
a nivel de el medio ambiente y también
tener un impacto social
estamos tratando de mezclar esos mundos
que es el descubrir los océanos
descubrir el salvamos descubrir lo que
es los universos marinos y toda la fauna
que está alrededor para la mente dándole
una oportunidad a jóvenes que quizás no
tuvieron la oportunidad en su vida de
poder conocer el salón grande poder
viajar por participar en un velero y
entonces los programas tienen esas
particularidades de descubrir el medio
ambiente y de manera paralela
descubrirse como como individuo como ser
humano dentro de ese magnífico medio
si además que se conocerse a sí mismo en
el comportamiento como los demás en un
espacio reducido no es lo mágico que
tiene un barco es que te permite de
bueno
quizás proyectarse en el horizonte pero
al mismo tiempo no está solo lo haces en
colaboración con un grupo con un equipo
tienes que aprender a negociar
las frustraciones uno necesita que la
gente trabaje juntos para levantar las
reglas para bajar las velas para hacer
la cocina entonces es realmente convivir
y aprender la la autoayuda y aprender a
cómo cómo poder
a tomar también un tiempo de pausa hay
mucha gente que viene sobre el barco es
como que la vida lo lleva a tomar muchas
decisiones y quizás no tenga tantas
oportunidades y es ahí donde uno puede
tomar una pausa y decir bueno qué es lo
que yo quiero hacer y uno de los
objetivos es que descubran el medio
marino es que descubran el salón y por
eso por eso a veces tenemos
participantes que van a estudiar en el
instituto del mar y que vuelven como
marinos con nosotros eso es sobre las
cosas que las dos estamos orgullosos
-mariano y cómo llegaste tú al echo
maris
es una buena pregunta es terminando
terminando
yo empecé a navegar con el equipo de
donde mira el set mercat cuando fuimos a
la antártida volví tuvimos otra misión
que se llama miro por la planeta mil
días por el planeta y terminando esa
misión hubo una conexión con el grupo de
comares y tuve la oportunidad de de
proponer una ayuda para reflexionar cómo
se como se podrían organizar los
programas y tener un impacto social
fuerte con jóvenes que normalmente no es
no es fácil
que tengan esa oportunidad entonces como
como darle la oportunidad a este grupo
de gente que vive en situación
vulnerable de situaciones difíciles que
sean a nivel de salud mental o de nivel
toxicomanía o simplemente un momento de
difícil de la vida y darles esa
oportunidad como reflexionar a programas
que permitan tener un cambio y una
posibilidad que se hace a nivel humano
profesional también porque uno de los
programas que tenemos es con un amplio
bloque beck
y es bueno así así fueron ya van seis
años que estoy colaborando para ellos
navegando hablábamos ahorita cuando te
presente mariano de tu trabajo tú eres
responsable de la acción social en qué
consiste ese trabajo en el marco de eco
maris
como como te decía antes ahí hay teorías
que hay dos objetivos principales la
parte del medio ambiente y la parte de
la acción social que no están separadas
todo esto es son vasos comunicantes no y
mi trabajo por ejemplo es una vez que se
eligen los grupos de jóvenes en el
programa que están que son jóvenes entre
18 y 35 años que vienen durante dos
semanas
tenemos 4 el año pasado tenemos cuatro
grupos de que estamos durante dos
semanas mi trabajo es en colaboración
con vuelvo allí que es la coordinadora
del proyecto es ayudar a preparar el
grupo porque los jóvenes que llegan ahí
llegan sin conocerse la mayoría nunca
han navegado y tomamos un par de días
para crear el espíritu de grupo para
crear un grupo porque llegan son gente
sola que nunca habían vivido juntos y mi
trabajo entre otras cosas pero mi
trabajo entre otras cosas es crear un
grupo que esté lo más listo posible para
poder pasar dos semanas juntos e ir a
navegar y aprender a navegar entonces es
una dos semanas entonces en honduras dos
semanas la formación exacto exacto y son
dos días de preparación son dos semanas
de navegar y nunca se sabe para dónde
vamos de ideas descubrir lo más que se
pueda en el salón about pero depende de
los vientos depende de las maneras
depende del clima que tenemos entonces
como como ayuda a esos grupos a
adaptarse a lo no saber qué es lo que va
a pasar en este momento es muy
interesante porque estamos viviendo un
momento de incertidumbre
y la idea es que los preparamos dos días
dos semanas y después nos acompañamos
durante un año
tener un apoyo en colaboración con los
garrafones and flow
sí es cierto que la pandemia de kobe 19
ha cambiado de alguna forma las reglas
del juego del juego mundial no pero una
vez que terminan me dice me hablan de
dos semanas con un grupo vuelven a tomar
otro grupo y vuelven a continuar el
viaje
exacto durante el diría que el tiempo de
explotación el tiempo de trabajo no se
puede empezar antes de abrir porque hace
mucho frío y tampoco se puede innovar
más tarde que mediados de octubre porque
es el amago la razón por el frío
entonces tenemos un periodo estival
donde las actividades se mezclan el
programa que están que tenemos en los
últimos años hace cuatro sin este será
el quinto año tenemos el 44 grupos de
dos semanas
a eso se intercalan los cadetes que
vienen
de la marina que viene a aprender a
navegar también tenemos grupos de altos
estudios comerciales tienen un profesor
con un grupo de trabajo y para la
mantilla y un programa que se llama
plancton cósmico donde se se invita a
científicos a investigar a analizar
el cosmos la astrología
una astronomía a una de las dos siempre
me equivoco y tenemos también los
trabajos de astronomía y la astrología
es otra cosa y tenemos científicos que
estudian también el plancton entonces
esa semana hay gente del público que
viene a colaborar con ellos entonces se
mezclan las diferentes programas se van
mezclando las acciones -mariano hacíamos
alusión ahorita a este este viaje que tú
hiciste con el 64 en la misión antártida
se puede comparar de alguna forma la
misión antártida del z4 con lo que estás
haciendo ahora en eco maris
es lo que se puede comparar es que él
mismo si uno están dos semanas en un
barco en vez de un año
los grupos que llegan un barco 'la
tienen que aprender a vivir juntos tiene
que aprender a hablar los conflictos
tienen que aprender a cocinar juntos
tienen que aprender a colaborar y hacer
confianza al otro salir de la zona de
confort yo creo que el desafío de los
jóvenes que llegan al barco con nosotros
por algunos es casi como en un año la
antártida porque hay jóvenes que nunca
han salido de su casa o están jugando en
los videogames durante 14 16 horas y de
repente tienen que vivir con gente
colaborar aprender a navegar yo creo que
el desafío de salir de la zona de
confort es algo que se puede comparar
porque para los que no están al tanto de
los de este viaje del set 4 fueron
muchísimo más que dos semanas
si fuera algo estuvimos un año así que
hace un año
la idea era ir ir hasta hasta la
antártida esperar que el hielo nos
atrape y hace una serie de
investigaciones a nivel cambios
climáticos e impacto de cambios
climáticos firmarlo y cuando él vieron
sedes de hábitat volver y todo eso duró
casi 430 días y bueno eso es otro
desafío pero pablo lo interesante es que
en esa época éramos profesionales que
decidimos de ir a hacer ese trabajo
atrás reducido perdón
el grupo era más reducido también éramos
éramos 13 personas pero me parece
interesante hacer el lazo que muchos los
jóvenes
que llegan al programa que han estado
especialmente vienen con con inquietudes
vienen con con quizás un sentimiento que
nada va a cambiar que su vida va a
seguir así
hay gente que tiene poca confianza que
tiene pocos sueños y lo que es
interesante es que ellos pueden pasar a
través de esos miedos y reinventarse y
reinventar una posibilidad de nosotros
80% de los jóvenes que pasan desde hace
4 años en nuestro proyecto vuelven al
trabajo o lo vuelve a los estudios
algunos de ellos 15 a 20 por ciento a
decidir a trabajar al medio al medio
marino y que se vuelven en actores
sociales muy importantes para mí es ese
es objetivo de la acción social del
barco me parece muy importante
lamariano el lunes 8 de junio próximo es
el día mundial de los océanos tienen
alguna actividad planeada
si nos gustaría para el 8 me gustaría
estar navegando con viento en popa y
bombas
y aprovechando aprovechando el universo
marino que tenemos aquí al lado el flow
salones es increíble pero bueno lo que
vamos a hacer esperando hasta que
tengamos la posibilidad de poder ir a
navegar es sacar vídeos que habíamos
hecho el año pasado
hablar comentar mostrar los diferentes
programas que tenemos a través los
vídeos que la gente pueda descubrir el
sangrado que pueda descubrir ese mundo
fascinante de los modelos de los
mamíferos marinos del plancton y de las
diferentes ciudades que están alrededor
entonces vamos vamos a mostrar lo que
hemos filmado los últimos en los últimos
años sobre todo el año pasado
mariano muchísimas gracias te gustaría
agregar algo en particular antes de
terminar esta entrevista
si pablo en estos momentos de donde hay
mucha incertidumbre en a los jóvenes de
tener una posibilidad alternativa de la
educación clásica y lo que lo que se
trata de hacer en el comal is es vivir
una experiencia para que esa experiencia
se convierta en un elemento de cambio
es algo que realmente funciona que
espero que podamos seguir haciendo por
muchos años más
mariano muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista a radio canadá internacional
gracias pablo que tengas un día
[Música]